did you like Stephen King I did I only
met him one day he he came down to the
set at the beginning of shooting
very soft-spoken gentleman did he look
like someone who look you gotta have
demons to write that he writes no
you don't think so no I do
I think
creative
but why is it always so dark there's
something don't you think there's
something going on if 95 of what you're
right is really really dark what's
what's I don't I I have mixed I have I
have mixed emotions about that makes
thinking about that right one of my
clients called and said Dee I'm taking
this other class and the teacher said
that anybody that is involved in horror
films in in any way is damaging their
energy and and their psychic I said well
I'm telling you that's